so by early December 1914 the punishing
advance of the Germans have been stopped
by the Allies before the Germans made it
to Paris but had been stopped at a great
cost a sickening cost but now the armies
had settled into the trenches and we
know what the trenches were hell not
some metaphorical approximation of hell
but actual hell hell on earth artillery
mortars machine gun fire snipers
shrapnel screams of the wounded and
dying and on top of that the environment
rain and sleet and snow and flooded
trenches and freezing cold and of course
death was everywhere everywhere and
there seemed no end to the horror but on
Christmas Day 1914 the horror did stop
if only for a short time while men for a
moment recognized the men they were
fighting against as other men as other
men with the same hopes and dreams and
desires that they had themselves and the
chief
of all hope where's peace and this is an
excerpt of how the Christmas truce
unfolded according to Henry Williamson a
British Army officer who is there and
here's what he wrote four weeks we had
lived in flooded trenches the Germans
were 80 yards away our trench was and
fellated we lost many men shot by
snipers night after night since the
tailing off the Battle of Ypres x' we
had toiled in the parapets filling
sandbag with clay mud squelched through
muddy lagoons of woodland tracks
carrying rations duckboards pumps and
ammunition we were volunteers rushed out
to help general French's shattered
Expeditionary Force a few weeks before
we had been schoolboys bank clerks
undergraduates medical students now our
lives were ravaged some of us the young
ones who thought of their mothers were
near to despair we were without hope
without horizon at first
trench life had been interesting even
enjoyable it was fun cooking our own
bacon and making tea in the wood while
shrapnel cracked overhead good sport
stalking the wild geese in the marshes
satisfying to feel the soft hairs of our
unshaven chins the regulars were decent
chaps heroes of Mons but the rains fell
and the trenches filled almost waist
high after a few days we could scarcely
move our legs nor did we seem to need
food at night we dragged ourselves out
of the ditches and moved about uncaring
of bullets aimed at random in the dark
all night we worked carrying parties
pumping fatigues parapet building at
dawn we slid in the water again and set
ourselves to endure the gray daylight
even now so long afterwards when I hear
rain on the tiles overhead the ghost of
that time makes me draw the blankets
closer around my neck on Christmas Eve
of 1914 we were in the support line
about 200 yards inside the plug stared
wood it was freezing our overcoats were
as stiff as boards our boots were too
hard to move but we rejoiced as the mud
was hard too also happy thought we would
be able to sleep that night inside a new
block house of oak boughs and sandbags
called Piccadilly Hotel no bed but the
cold earth no blankets even but sleep
sleep
then came a message from brigade
headquarters broad I think by second
lieutenant Bruce Barron's father of the
Warrick's wiring parties were required
in no-man's land all night and there
would be a moon we would have to work
only 50 yards from the German machine
guns in the white house opposite the
eastern edge of the wood two hours later
we filed out of the dark trees into the
naked moonlit terror of no-man's land
holding our shovels besides our faces in
hope of protection against the expected
mortar blast the moon was high and white
among the frozen clouds we were visible
someone slipped with a Clank of a spade
or rifle we flung ourselves on our faces
and waited but the battlefield was as
silent as the moon for an hour we worked
in silence in a most mysterious sound
lessness what had happened we began to
talk naturally as we drove in stakes and
pulled out concertinas of prepared wire
there was no rifle fire either up or
down the line from way up north beyond
appraise to south beyond our mentiras
and the French army at midnight we heard
laughing as we worked we heard singing
from the German lines carols the tunes
of which we knew I noticed a very bright
light on a tall pole raised in their
lines down opposite the east lanx trench
in front of the convent a Christmas tree
with lighted candles was set on their
parapet
the unreal moonlight life went on
happily cries of c'mon over Tommy we
won't fire at you a dark figure
approached me hesitatingly a trap I
walked towards it with a bumping heart
Merry Christmas
English friend we shook hands
tremulously then I saw that the light on
the pole was the morning star the star
in the east it was Christmas morning all
Christmas Day gray and khaki figures
mingled and talked in no-man's land the
picks and spades rang in the hard ground
it was strange to stare at the dead we
had only glimpsed at swiftly from the
trenches the shallowest graves were dug
filled and set with crosses knocked
together from lengths of rationed
boxwood marked with indelible pencil for
king and country for fatherland own free
height fatherland and freedom freedom
freedom how was this we were fighting
for freedom and our cause was just we
were defending Belgium civilization
these fellows in gray were good fellows
they were strangely just men like
ourselves how can we lose the war
English comrade our cause is just
we are ringed with enemies the war was
thrust on us we are defending our
parents our homes our German soil the
most shaking staggering thought that
both sides thought they were fighting
for the same cause
the war was a terrible mistake people at
home did not know this then the idea
came to the young and callow soldier
that if only he could tell them at home
what was really happening and if the
German soldiers told their people the
truth about us the war would be over but
he hardly dared to think it even to
himself the next day was quiet and the
next waving hands from the trenches by
day singing and reflected blaze of
trench bonfires at night it was a lovely
time on the third afternoon came a
message from the Germans at midnight our
staff officers visit and we must fire
our automatic pistol on but we will fire
higher nevertheless please keep
undercover at 11 p.m. Berlin midnight we
saw flashes going away into the air
two days later an army order came from
GHQ to the effect that men found
fraternizing with the enemy would be
court-martialed and if found guilty
would suffer the death penalty and again
in that place the very lights soared
over no man's land at night then bullets
cut showers of splinters from trees and
sometimes human flesh and bone so hope
sank into the mud again but did not die
despite a withering anew as each
or human unit fell in machine gun and
mortar blast and colossal reverberating
rending of the shells of those four
years the years whose truth seems to be
in communicable sometimes as one listens
to what people say here in the England a
generation died for it seems like almost
pre-war again can it be that we lack
imagination to see the other fellow as
ourselves
Henry Williamson continued to fight
he was eventually wounded by gas then
when he was declared unfit to serve in
the army he then volunteered for the Air
Force to see if that could get him back
to the front but he didn't make it back
to the front luckily because the war
ended the war ended but not before 20
million were wounded and 17 million men
were killed men just normal men gone
so this holiday season please think of
those men and women around the world in
the trenches now risking life and limb
for what they believe in for freedom and
think of the civilians trapped in those
hellish places suffering in the
merciless paths of war and finally as
Henry Williamson asked let us not lack
the imagination to think to think of
other men as men men like ourselves men
like us
you
Merry Christmas to all and may there be
peace on earth